For services that need
to deal with high or
variable request rates, choosing
the configuration that involves multiple
processes configured on potentially
multiple nodes, becomes necessary.
This is because the multi-process
configurations are the easiest way to
deal with scale, to deal with increases
in the incoming request rates.
What will do in such cases is we'll
scale out the service deployment,
by launching the same
service on multiple machines.
And so these are referred to
as scale out architectures.
A typical architecture could
then be organized as follows.
A front-end dispatching or
load balancing component
would a route to the incoming
request to the appropriate or
available machine that
implements the internet service.
This is in some sense similar to the
boss-worker pattern that we discussed
when we talked about structuring
multi-threaded parallel programs.
One possibility afterwards is that every
single one of the nodes is capable for
executing any possible
step that's required for
the processing of the request.
And that they can handle any possible
request that may come in from
the external users.
The other possibility is that the nodes
can be specialized to execute only some
specific step, or some specific
steps in the request processing, or
they can be specialized only for
certain types of requests.
This is again analogous to what
we talked about when discussing
the boss-worker pattern, that
the workers may be general purpose, so
they may perform any processing, or they
may be specialized for certain tasks.
We can further classify these
architectures as those having
a property of being
functionally homogenous.
Like when all of the workers performed,
are capable of performing,
any processing step.
Or, as functionally heterogeneous,
like in the case where certain notes
are specialized in certain functions.